there were just hundreds of snakes in
this temple just waiting for us to show
up what why aren't they biting that guy
this is ridiculous delete delete
what excited you most
about doing this movie honestly like
very much the chance to work with both
of you like that was very gonna take
some answers
i just told you this ten minutes wow
okay i'm sorry you've got to think of
something new fast um he's giving the
very diplomatic answer it's
when i like got the script i knew that
you guys were doing it and they were
like you know read this and say if you
respond to it i was like the level of
bad this script would have to be for me
to not want to do it with you guys
involved because it's so high because
you choose bad material in general like
you can consistently choose i read it
that's what i aim for what excited you
the most
the wig for me i've always i've always
wanted to have long hair i've never had
long hair in my life i just can't do it
and your personality changed when you
walked out it really was uncomfortable
she was her thing she was the wig was
when she came out she was a whole vibe
which cast member would you take with
you on a treasure hunt and why honestly
i'm sorry to not name either of you guys
but thomas he plays mustache he plays he
plays monster yes and he is just
saying
he plays mustache
what is the hardest thing about shooting
in the jungle
i have to ask because i didn't do any of
it
the challenge was just i was in the
jumpsuit so i couldn't use the restroom
so i just chose not to drink liquids i
got it which paid off beautifully
watching sandra run in the jungle with
high heels on and a jumpsuit
i gotta say it was nothing short of like
an olympic like event like i still don't
know how you did it sondra and channing
what was it like shooting um the leeches
scene in the movie that was day two that
was day two day two i literally walked
on was like hi everyone um my name is
chan
this is uh my butt and this is gonna be
my own set today let's all have a great
shoot all right
let's go team i can definitely say that
if you told my 18 year old self that uh
that i was going to be in that situation
[Laughter]
it was good it was brave i was just
looking up just going yeah this is
happening
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that come on
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off
are you feeling suckers
whip it like a banana
feels like there's more holy mother of
god ah they're just sucking on my butt
like a big old jamba juice
[Music]
you